when you finish a screenplay on spec
what's protocol when you're done well
you finish it up and get all your
buddies to read it until what you think
because this is like you only get one
first read on that and that's that's
hard for me because I like to get it out
there see what the agent thinks you know
as soon as possible and it's a mistake
you should hold it until it's done
I have trouble taking that advice but
you send it to your agent or producers
or whoever your contacts are in that
world and you wait to see what they say
I mean it's it's pretty simple you have
very little power over it once they take
it I have this one script that has been
overwhelmingly positive feedback and
notes and has been at one agency for
about eight months you know going
through actors big movie stars reading
it or their people reading it anyways
and we'll wait for nine weeks and then
we'll hear well Matthew McConaughey
passed but that's okay we're going to
what he knows it okay nine weeks later
well woody harrelson bad but that's okay
we're going to Josh Brolin and it just
sits there and people read it and it you
know I do nothing I just sit and I'm
happy that these agencies and these this
talent has something of mine to read you
know maybe they'll see my name on it
what if you don't have the agent or
manager to give it to I mean if you're
let's say or a new writer that doesn't
have a foundation hasn't been in LA that
long you know there there are online
resources blacklist is one of them where
you can send in the script and have it
covered have it read coverage is this
thing where you know it's like a book
report on your script where they all the
studios do that and they'll give you a
little score you know and you can get
you can pay people that do it
professionally but I would say that
right now these these competitions that
a lot of like I know Austin Film
Festival has a very prestigious one but
sending your script in if you win a
couple of awards that's something that
might get some leeway in a sending it to
a
an agency you know like normally I would
say that almost never works I've never
heard of anybody being read because of a
query letter but if you have awards
maybe it would work you know I mean look
there's no set way to do anything in
this business like everything is like a
twisty turny you know chutes and ladders
kind of thing so you just try everything
just throw everything at it and I mean
that's how I finance movies that's how I
got all my movies done you just try
everything and see what works out and be
open to something working working out in
a way that you didn't expect
you